Healthcare has always been an innovative
field and we see that now more than ever
as technology advances the healthcare
industry is undergoing a transformative
revolution with AI leading the way
increased AI adoption in healthcare is
bolstering our health care system by
enhancing the efficiency and
effectiveness of preventative care with
deep learning and predictive analytics
don't you want to be at the forefront of
advancement in the healthcare industry
and impact the future of medical care
Udacity is AI for healthcare nano degree
program gives you the skills to do just
that
be prepared to apply machine learning
and data science techniques to cutting
edge work done across the healthcare
industry including research labs at
hospitals product teams and help tech
company's R&D departments and medical
schools and more get hands-on experience
slicing and visualizing 3d medical image
data in a virtual machine using Udacity
hands-on workspace which allows you to
perform tasks like measuring brain size
to determine Alzheimer's progression
you'll learn to develop machine learning
algorithms using electronic health
records 2d and 3d medical imaging and
wearable device data in order to perform
more accurate diagnosis predict health
conditions and more join the healthcare
revolution and enable enhanced medical
decision making
powered by machine learning to build the
treatments of the future enroll in
Udacity z' AI for healthcare nano degree
program today
you
[Music]